did she say 16 year olds are hotter than
26y olds yep she says exactly
that our favorite girl had a long 1 hour
video done on her but I don't want to
watch the whole thing this from Jay
Aubrey he did some research on our girl
pearl hey guys today I am here with my
sister Eva and she is going to give a
chicken co
tour I don't need no validation I don't
need no validation
yeah yeah okay you don't need no valid
except from Tik Tok a lot of you guys
have been asking questions so I kind of
ended up being like a full-time Tik Tok
like YouTuber by accident so we can see
Pearl was actually once pretty far
removed from the characters who make up
the manosphere in fact I doubt she even
knew who any of them were back when she
was making things like my first Vlog a
trip to Florida chicken coup tour wrong
wrong spelling and a mansion house tour
10 bedrooms okay so I'm going to show
you the front of the house 10 bedrooms
is crazy 10 bedroom rules is a lot see
Pearl herself comes from a very wealthy
sheltered background in Chicago with
both of her parents Dan and Jennifer
Davis being quite accomplished software
engineers in their own right Jennifer
being listed as the former CEO of
davisware a multi-million dollar company
of the couple founded together she's now
the CEO of another organization she
founded to B exponential which is
described as an online community seeking
to provide tangible and realistic advice
to women and mothers specifically
navigating Parenthood or Life as a whole
their website also mentions that b
exponential was built by women for women
ain't it crazy that this girl is arguing
for the treadon thing stay at home be a
wife have kids do all this other stuff
and her mom is a CEO women aren't
feminine enough women are this and you
see her arguing on podcast yelling at
people telling people off or being
aggressive and combative with people
it's just interesting that her whole
life experience even at home was the
opposite and by all accounts the way she
speaks about her family life and the
fact that her parents stayed together it
seems very contradictory with the whole
idea that cuz her mom is the
quintessential Modern Woman in a lot of
ways yeah right you can't be a CEO no
and be hyper feminine no that's just not
the way it works you can't run a company
successfully run multiple companies
successfully make all this money and
still be super the reason being is like
and when you're in the workplace there a
certain level of certain and all this
stuff that you need to do so it's just
interesting to me that she had a good
life growing up she was afforded a good
life by her parents based off being like
modern women or whatever it is and yet
she gets to this stage and all of a
sudden in 2 years she is advocated for
the exact opposite of literally what
created her mhm just
interesting the more I think the more
I'm like gosh the natural world world
order has has to be men women children
maybe government I haven't decid I have
to think more about
that wasn't your mom the president was
she the leader of the
company what was my you're researching
my family now huh they might have titled
at one thing or another they did that to
get some Grant from the government or
something I don't remember but so in
this yeah is that a
crime so she's basically saying her mom
defrauded the government she wasn't
actually a CEO so either she's
lying or she don't know what she's lying
to keep up her image and making her
parents look like fraudsters or she
doesn't or she's telling the truth and
her parents are fraudsters and she
openly admitted it to protect her
reputation either way it don't look
good I mean listen I don't care what
crime my mom admitted or did there's no
way I'm saying that [__] in
public but we all build different you
want to expose your parents imagine your
kids online she's not realizing that
what she's saying she's talking about
fraud she doesn't realize it she's just
like well my mom was not actually that
she's just saying like that she's not
saying committing fraud and stuff like
she doesn't know that what that what
you're talking about is illegal so in
this yeah is that a crime yeah you
probably shouldn't say that on air the
main takeaway here is that Pearl got to
experience a lavish childhood as a
result of her parents both having
high-paying jobs in fact one of the
times Pearl first blew up was thanks to
a Tik Tok she made about a giant water
slide her dad bought her and her
siblings yeah some people just live a
completely different life than the rest
of us no I know why she thinks a
Lamborghini costs 5050 Grand y this
video is wild they did their research
they did their research shout out to
this guy J Aubrey is killing it but this
was Pearl's first taste of online
startup a glimpse into a life where she
didn't have to work at corporate job
with kanuk multa selling printers a
position she absolutely hated and it was
literally like the worst sales job of my
life like I hated it I hated it so much
but if she had never sold printers we
never would have gotten these wonderful
song parodies she posted to LinkedIn we
just took a DNA test turns down we're
100% the best even when we're going
crazy cuz we do see problems that's a
human in US bling bling then we solve
them that's a Salesman in I'm starting
to see why she hated working
there yo don't lie yo with that last one
she on to something I think the boy
Drizzy got to get in content he need to
call her on his cell
phone he's not what does charl man
always say too much goddamn
Min yeah you know Co was the weird time
for all of us I'll just say that my pear
from I'll you I we got in the back it's
still better than her recent music
feminism is the worst thing ever yeah we
get our money yeah we get our job yeah
we dumped our high school heartthrob but
then we end up alone on anti-depressants
all alone according to one article I
found from 2020 Pearl was first gaining
traction on Tik Tok after just several
months of creating her account her
initial claim to fame being her breakup
quiz series in which she wrote a bunch
of questions that viewers could then
send to their ex Partners to fill out
for Pearl to post publicly and it was
pretty successful too posting the best
answers from a pool of nearly 9,000
submissions this article though also
makes sure to note that Pearl herself
has yet to send the quiz to anyone in
her past considering she's never
actually been in a real relationship
Pearl stating I actually have not had a
boyfriend that was serious enough for me
to send it to hence why I had my
followers take it the only long-term
relationship I can think of is a guy I
talked
to
y'all noticing the pattern with these
dating
coaches just saying just saying
only
huh what don't say that what what what I
do I this crazy which in itself is
totally fine and normal everyone moves
at their own pace and there's no shame
in dating later in life the except PE
might slightly disagree just because
you're 35 and you're single doesn't mean
you'll be single at 40 at 60 at 70 but
the problem is at 35 you've lost all the
things that men value that that's the
problem cuz men men value femininity
fertility and they value youth so you
can't say you're youthful when you're
almost halfway through your life like
you can't say you're fertile when you're
you're you're about to have geriatric
pregnancy so it's like and you look
worse than you did at at 25 right so the
way you're thinking is like a woman not
to mention it's almost been 3 years
since this article was published and to
my knowledge Pearl still has yet to be
in an actual long-term relationship
though there was the time she briefly
dated the angry Tik Tok reaction guy not
for very long her ex-best friend of 22
years Emily says that despite her brief
time with angry reactions the girl has
still never had a serious relationship
has she ever been engaged no never and
she's never even been in a serious
relationship like honest to God she I
mean her and W like that wasn't even
like that doesn't even count at all
because what was that and that's where
we run into a bit of a problem Pearl as
someone who has evidently never been
married never been engaged never even
held down a boyfriend longer than a few
months still somehow has the ner to tell
other women what to do in their
relationships publicly it's her job to
do that a huge part of her brand relies
on judging other people's marriages from
afar girl likes the idea of being
married she wants a family someday and
wants to have kids but does that by
itself mean she's a reliable source on
how a marriage needs to work what
exactly gives her the right to tell
others how they're doing things wrong
when she herself hasn't even experienced
a relationship the way she thinks she
wants it Pearl's relationship advice
might as well be completely [__]
discarded even by her own metric I've
noticed a lot of therapists are like
older single women and I'm kind of like
if you can't maintain a relationship why
would I take advice from you I'm just
this is just something I've noticed yeah
like why would I take advice from you if
you can't maintain a relationship I
didn't say it she
did fourth thing I've learned from the
manosphere and I'm not going to talk
about if this is true or not true women
are always willing to leave you for a
better option women today are less
marriageable than ever before like women
can and will take all of your money
women will do things like withhold sex
if they don't do like chores or
something she was so excited to share
what she had learned in fact fact that
she even brought her family into the mix
which had some varying results today I
have a special guest on the channel my
little sister
Amelia she's super excited to be here
I'm going to be showing her some of
Kevin Samuel's Savage moments because
she would not be she was not willing to
sit down for a full clip so yeah her
sister does not give even a single [__]
just please let her go do you think
women get upset at men a lot depends do
you think they say things like men are
trash a lot do you think that's okay
sometimes really depends on the guy
you're talking about do you think but in
general do you think that's okay men are
trash men are trash like just in general
I don't know I don't really have an
opinion on that kind of that's how the
most normal people would
here red pill okay what's that I got BS
to
pay she 13 like this is a question I've
never asked myself I was like would I
ever sit a 12-year-old down and be like
you want to watch some Kevin Samuels
they're kind of um they're kind of
players a little bit you ready
m stop looking like I'm torturing you
why the hell are you going to pay full
price for a goddamn car that's been used
if I'm going to invest into you I need
to know you are not used man what does
your YouTube feed look like on a daily
basis it literally looks like this stuff
it's like men's dating
advice you are so
[Music]
single
[__]
[Music]
some of you are single and some of you
are so
single you are so sick oh my God yo the
way that [__] came out yo play man I
want to hear it again it literally looks
like this stuff it's like men's dating
advice you are so
single someone had to say
it
[__] upper cut the [__] be your
old sister this God
damn y they all taking turns on her but
why are you also exposing her to the
repulsion that is your community I mean
these comments are insane she has no
life in her she's going to do hard drugs
when she gets older she for sure is not
attracting anyone in life she will die
alone talking about the 13 of course
it's the Internet it's wild out there it
is is wild yo
these red pill dudes is straight up
losers they heard a 13-year-old being
like I don't really care about this
manosphere stuff and they're like this
girl's [__] stupid you're going to be
here existing my guy and then they're
going to yeah so that was Kevin Samuels
what did you
think did you think what he said was
true or false I don't know if I tried
showing my little sister some of Pearl's
videos I think she decked me in the face
I prefer Kevin Samuels to fresh and Fit
I prefer Minecraft youtubers watching
Pearl try to get regular people on board
with her new belief system is truly a
sight to Behold a girl will only love a
guy like that's like the best she can
get but if she has a better option like
that makes more money is more attractive
is like just a better allaround option
she'll leave her current like boyfriend
or husband for them oh I mean just hear
you could tell her friend isn't nearly
as invested in this conversation as
Pearl is basically the candy store
analogy is like C sex is candy and girls
get it right away but most guys don't
have access to sex till their late 20s
early 30s so if you get married like
before that they think that like girls
should put up with cheating
basically I know because like it's not
fair to the guys because like now at 35
they finally put out their money right
they got to the gym for 5 years did all
this stuff
now they get to have sex with a lot of
people so why would they only settle for
one well then why did they get married
why did they get
married why not just stay single and go
sleep around you know I think we spent
so much time on YouTube we don't realize
like just go
outside this whole red pill stuff is so
goofy like nobody in the real world
takes it seriously this is a niche thing
for n me when like in a
little circle jerk of people that think
yeah this [__] is not real life for most
people people not taking this [__]
seriously man people are just trying to
make it through the day the last thing
anyone wants to do is listen to Just
pearly things tell them what age
disqualifies women from finding a
partner who cares also asking this
person about age probably isn't the best
idea did she say 16 year-olds are hotter
than 26y olds yep she says exactly
that okay
okay this is wild this is this is wild
this this
wild I mean you could have chose a like
46 year olds and I be like maybe you can
make that take nah 26
26 God damn goly 16-year-old chicks are
hotter than you can't even repeat that
right you can't even yeah exactly moving
right along yeah but you know you like
no [__] and you weird I say it move
moving y you're talking about underage
girls are more oh my God moving right
along
I no no just the fact the fact the fact
that just the fact that you want to
explain this [__] you you don't have to
explain this [__] it's not I want to
it's just like yeah there's the geezers
out there you know the red pill stuff
the more you peer back the lers you just
you hear weird stuff and like eventually
they just they just want to [__] like a
14-year-old virgin like that's what it
sound like the more and more you peel
back to letters I sound like they want
go after kids it get weirder and weirder
[__] you mean man before it's like yo
18's legal and then I was like yo 16
year-olds are
hotter yall weird I don't care what
nobody says you what the [__] was she
cooking here not that it's literally any
excuse that she's doing this because
what she is doing I can't even put into
words how disgusting it is but I've
known her since 20 to I do not think she
thinks that way if she does her all over
again I don't care but I don't think she
does I think she does it to rev people
up and to get more views and to get more
money so all that to say I'm curious to
see once she does find a husband and
find a man is she going to keep this act
up cuz is she going to find somebody
that shares these exact views with her
or is she going to meet someone and be
like okay I don't actually think this
way according to both Emily and angry
reactions that Pearl's bizarre obsession
with churning out the most mind-numbing
takes imaginable seem to happen
overnight cuz a lot of people be in my
is be like she had to have been like
this when y'all was dating bro no she
wasn't at all she was not like this bro
and we know she used to be normal is
what happened then how do you go for
making such innocuous Vlogs with your
family to outright pandering to the
lowest form of men on Twitter with no
shame well without making any
unreasonable assumptions here we know
from Emily that Pearl has been
consistently fixated on finding a
boyfriend in the past staying up late
into the night and pouring over all the
numbers and information she could
possibly find in hopes of finally
attaining a high value man of her liking
hly like sad because she was always
trying to figure out what could she do
to get a husband I always told her that
she did too much research she was always
online like looking up relationship
facts and stuff like that and and she
would be up late like doing it I'm like
just stop yeah just stop doing that like
let's just naturally look for a man
which again is fine everyone deserves to
find love except I don't know how she
expects to do it when this is how she
advertises herself to the public now I'm
not going to sit here and pretend I know
exactly why she pivoted so hard to Red
Pill content we simply don't know the
definitive reason as to why she's so
susceptible to the Manos feere and oh
wait there is a reason and she said it
herself oh okay or even girls they'll
ask me like how can you listen to this
man and I have one one answer for
you low
selfesteem yeah that's real her answer
to the question why do you listen to the
sexist trash basically boils down to oh
it's because I hate myself from a young
age I haven't thought highly of myself I
never thought that I deserved a lot to
be honest um I never thought of myself
as a queen um and I never thought of
myself super highly I'm going to I'm
going to just be honest here from a
young age um I was what you call humbled
okay most of my friends right were
generally like more attractive than me I
was never the hot friend most guys even
that the average guys they would ask me
about my friend first and if that didn't
work out then then they would come
crawling to me
so yeah um I would say low self-esteem
um that's the main one and yeah being
humbled that's why I can listen to
manosphere
content honestly this like might seem
like the most human thing Pearl said to
date MH and I think what she describes
the exact reason why most dudes get into
the
red they get rejected a lot they want
answers and they have this ideology that
says I used to be like you I used to be
a loser now I have seven women on
my and you and you can be like like me
that's it that's how all these people
fall into it you know this idea that
these are all experts and all this other
stuff it's like no they were all dweebs
and nerds who couldn't get any and then
they got a little bit of Fame and
notoriety and now they're PR like based
off this scam that they're selling
they're able to then Propel themselves
forward and know for her it's even
funnier because even though she got the
nor R she still can't get a boyfriend so
obviously the you know at least the
repel guys to get laate at least she
can't even get a boy like that's crazy
ain't that crazy all this two minutes
you can't get a husband
still they still not looking for you
that's a crazy failure but you hear it
like it's from a place of hurt that's
where all these people come from that's
where all this [__] is projected from it
doesn't make it okay or whatever it's
just that's the pathology that I've seen
it's often scammers or people who were
really hurt who buy into the scam but
that's been my experience of life well
people that can benefit from or people
that
can that that that it's either people
that can take profit of people yeah or
people that kind of see an answer Li to
whatever the that how they were feeling
yeah if that's that's yeah that's fine
if I was Pro I would honestly just fake
a marriage I pay somebody and fake a
marriage no that's not good cuz they
will know who will know people will know
people will know if you fake a marriage
like that and you put it on blast like
that people are going to look into it
because they're going to well how how
would they know you can literally fake
it very easy how would they know it's
fake they're going to know how would
they know they're going to know they
interview the guy you just don't realize
what we just need a be right
now
so I would honestly f one just so a lot
of this criticis I don't think she can
keep it keep it up that's what I'm
saying she would fake one and then that
thing will backfire into knowing it's a
fake one and then things will get worse
why would it backfire I don't understand
how would people back I think that she
would get discovered like people she
would fake a mar I don't think she's
she's smart enough to be able to fake a
marriage to the Grand public
and things not slip I mean people do
that all the time there's celebrities
who do that who have fake marriages why
would you just a matter of getting
somebody you pay them you say yes to
they do the whole paperwork stuff and
it's like just don't talk about it
that's it I mean hey who knows maybe he
would come out I just think for a
business move it' be great for her in
the short term but I in the short yeah
okay and I mean what you think she going
be on YouTube for 10 years come on bro
theam and her Channel been dying but
what what do you think about the topic
what topic that was no topic we just
discuss a whole life of pearl we we
discuss a whole life of pearl it's
nothing that really I didn't know about
it's really just the wonderful life of
pearl like you said the most thing that
I like what I learned the most is where
is her villain story why the origin
story The Origin the villain origin
story where of of of of how it started
and the link to other all the other
villain which I
understand I get I get the sentiment and
I get that that's the only thing where I
can actually understand where it's from
and and I can understand the human
That's The Human Side of Pearl and after
that she went on a whole other tangent
that I already knew about but but ain't
it okay this is the thing that's funny
go ahead Pearl has the knowledge she's
open she's willing to let her man sleep
around okay she don't want that she said
but she said she's open to it but that's
why franch hold up hold up hold up
that's what she said say she's open to
it she has the knowledge she knows all
the
answers but in her friend group she's
the one who's not married the ones who
don't have the knowledge who are not
down with this my man go to sleep with
everybody they found somebody and just
lonely things is still out here giving
out advice ain't it crazy the red pill
person can't get the blue pill person's
results cuz cuz cuz rep cuz red pill is
not for
girls red pill red pill red pills rep
pills is for it's going to function more
on girl if you're not so good-look guy
it has more chances of working on you
than if you're not so good-look girl
okay the reason being is that guys and
girls don't look for the same thing a
guy is not going to care that she says
Al the that's not what they're looking
for and actually her promoting herself
the way she is promoting herself is the
opposite of what every
red pill guy wants what she says is what
every what every red red pill guy wants
what she says is what every red pill guy
wants what she is is the absolute the
the opposite of that they don't want who
she
is what she says is rep pill who she is
is not how is who she is not she talks a
lot she's not obedient she she always
butts heads with people she she's not
rep pill pearly things is her being is
not the way she's function the way she
is she's a career woman she's career
driven that's not red Bill everything
that comes out of her mouth is though so
when it's going to be time to not talk
about what you do but doing what you do
it's not going to work because you're
not she's her mom I I think um I think
for a lot of people who fall into these
kinds of movements um I think from her
you can kind of see where a lot of it
comes up even if they come from a good
family all this other stuff if they just
not had luck with the opposite sex then
all of a sudden they're very susceptible
to a lot of these scams and that's just
what it is with her and now she's
realized that she can perpetuate it for
her own Financial benefits so she's
doing her thing that's why everyone who
s knows her it's like yo I knew her two
years ago she was not like this at all
and she just switched it up why because
she said Also earlier I love the views
I'm addicted to Tik Tok views or
whatever it is some people get so
addicted to any of these things that
they'll just sell this Persona because
it makes some profits so someone that
was not I was not good that was a loser
back then considered a loser if they
haven't fixed themselves by the time
they get all this attention can be very
detrimental to who they are as a person
if you didn't fix yourself and you do
this YouTube stuff it can mess you up if
you're not fixed and you get into the
light of the people and then you go out
there and you get all this intention you
can crave for more cuz you never had
that imagine having a little sister
who's underage and putting putting her
in front of a red pill
audience like there's a certain level of
self-awareness you have to lack there's
a bit of like a stunted development I
have to imagine you have where you know
these people and the way that they
interact with folks and you bring your
little sister who doesn't believe in any
of this stuff and you subject her to
these kinds of comments or you don't
care or you don't care because that you
value the views more she values
friendship more than view she lost
friendship because of that she values
that more she lied on her friends she
lied on her friends she doesn't care if
her sister whatever it doesn't matter
it's not so much that oh you it's lack
of self-awareness nah Prim Cloud chasing
it's crackhead movement it's it's it's
Cloud chasing that's say all this that's
what these people you're addicted to the
Views and you're ready to subject people
you know whenever they want that crack
rock and then they ready to sell their
soul and sell their mas and their
daddies boot yeah that's what it is
that's what it is